why are the seventh-day adventists
are believing on the second coming of
christ
i wonder if there's a seventh-day
adventist who asks that question
why do we believe in the second coming
of christ it is the most popular
doctrine in the bible
especially in the new testament the
second coming of christ
is hinted at all the way in genesis 3 15
and i will put let me pray again father
please
continue to give me wisdom dear god
please before i rush off in my old
carnal way
give me wisdom father in jesus name amen
genesis 3 15 and i will put enmity
between thee and the woman between thy
seed and her seed
it shall bruise thy head and thou shall
bruise his heel
now this is the first mention of the
gospel on the earth
it also includes the second coming of
christ
and you say to me how do you say that go
to romans chapter 16.
quickly romans 16.
romans 16 the question was why do
adventists preach about the second
coming
if there's no second coming there's no
point for all this church and
vegetarian lifestyle and following jesus
and
there's no second coming why did christ
die
where's the time the second coming is
part of the overall
atonement of jesus christ do you have
romans 16
verse 20 if you have my version read it
for me what does verse 20 say
and the god of peace shall brew satan
under your heel or feet shortly now
what does that sound like genesis 3 15
now paul is writing this after jesus
went back to heaven
are you with me and he's saying now the
lord of face
shall or will there is a future crushing
of the head
that still has to occur at calvary
the head was crushed yes but i am told
if you kill a cockroach for many hours
is still alive
satan is the greatest cockroach in the
history of the world so he's still alive
you see
christ is coming back to finish him off
that's the second coming the lord of
peace will bruise satan
under your feet we will be part of that
final
blow that puts an end to satan we must
preach the second coming
let me tell you something about the
second coming also
jesus died to deliver us from the power
of sin
that power that leads us to drink and
curse and smoke and covet and whatever
else
he died to deliver us from the penalty
of sin
which is death he also died to deliver
us
from the presence of sin even though you
converted you're living a sinless life
all around you you see sin that has to
be dealt with
and so the entire work of atonement will
not
end until the end of the thousand years
when this world is made all over
satan destroyed all sin is destroyed and
a brand new world starts
that marks the end just the way azazel
when he was cast out into the wilderness
marked the end of the day of atonement
we must preach the second coming of
christ
jesus said let not your heart be
troubled you believe in god
belief also in me in my father's house
are many mansions
if it were not so i would have told you
i go to prepare a place for you
and if i go and prepare a place for you
i
will come again there's another reason
why jesus has to come back
follow me closely god does not lie
practice 1 verse 2 numbers 23 19
jesus says i am truth john 14 6.
deuteronomy 32 verse 4
the father's truth first john 5 6 the
holy ghost is truth
father son and holy ghost are all truth
they don't lie
now jesus said i'm coming back but long
before jesus said that on earth
he told abraham he would give him the
land of canaan am i right yes or no
yes go to hebrews 11.
hebrews 11. hundreds and hundreds of
years past
god told abraham you and your seed will
inherit this land
go to hebrews 11.
let's read verse 13.
if you have my version read for me what
does that say
these all died in faith meaning abraham
isaac jacob
sarah rebecca and rachel these all died
in faith
come on not having received the promise
but having seen them afar off and were
persuaded of them
and embraced them and confessed they
were strangers and pilgrims on the earth
now abraham died when abraham died
did he possess the land of canaan yes or
no
no did god tell him he'd have it yes did
abraham die without receiving that land
yes did god lie no so what does god have
to do
come back and raise him up to keep his
word
ah you all missed it you missed it
you had a good meal so you're sleeping
okay god
told abraham i'll give you this lamb
when abraham had to bury sarah you know
what he had to do
buy a cave because the land was not his
he had to buy
a cave from the the hittites
god has to come back
raise up abraham in order to keep his
word
that also tells us another very very
lovely story about god
not even death can keep god's word
from being fulfilled not even
death god will raise you from the death
to keep his word okay must come back we
preach the second coming